foreign
[Music]
Wormhole just so people can understand
it if you look at space and time we've
learned ever since Einstein in 1916 when
he Advanced the general theory of
relativity which is the modern
understanding of gravity we learned that
gravity
is the curvature of space-time
space-time yeah and what you do is when
you are Falling Towards something you
are simply sliding along
the fabric of your space time towards
whatever it was that you're saying is
attracting you
and so it's an interesting it's a
different
construct from just action at a distance
you're there I'm here we have gravity we
pull each other and that's it it's a
whole other thing going on
and if you think of space and time as
fabric right then you can distort the
fabric with the force of gravity Captain
I believe there's been a distortion in
the space-time Continuum exactly so if
you if you ask yourself
can I distort it in interesting ways
that might benefit what I want to do in
the universe for example I can get you
around among the planets using the
rockets that we've got and I get you
there before you die all right so moving
around the solar system takes days to
the Moon months to Mars years to the to
the outer planets and decade you know
maybe one or two decades to Pluto if you
want to put that keep that on your list
if you want to visit other stars
then every way we know to get there
exceeds a human life expectancy so you
have to find a way to shorten that
Journey knowing that the speed of light
is not just a good idea it's the law
right all right there's a speed limit to
how fast you can move in that fabric of
space and time the nearest star is four
light years away
at the speed of light you watch someone
go at the speed of light it'll take them
four years to do that you say okay well
let's just do that then but we're
nowhere near the speed of light all
right this is you know so so it's
hopeless and that's the nearest star so
you imagine let's is there a way
maybe you can
poke a hole
through or open up a hole
in the fabric of space and time
in a way that it's curved such that you
can take a shortcut from one location to
another nice so imagine if you had a
sheet
that so compress everything to a sheet
because otherwise it's hard to think of
bending four dimensions okay so our
universe is now a sheet so if I take
that sheet normally I'd have to travel
the full length of the sheet to get from
A to B and I want to do that before the
TV commercial okay and so what do you do
you warp the space
and then open up a hole
from one side to the other where the two
places are close in this higher
Dimension right and by doing so you
basically take this portal through come
out the other side unfold the paper the
page and you've traveled all that
distance in no time at all it basically
and the No Time part is well how much
did you warp the space in order to do
that how and if you warp it a lot it can
happen basically instantly like walking
through a doorway or if it's worth a
little less then it'll take you a little
longer but in all cases your effective
speed
is way greater than the speed of light
because you basically cheated
went across the other side
he says I'm asking myself after I watch
the movie the atom project if you really
can time travel with wormholes so Brian
we're talking about time travel and
wormholes uh I presume we I think
everyone knows with Einstein relativity
you can travel into a future all right
at least into the future of where you
once were so let's confine this to can
you go backwards in time do wormholes
enable this at all wormholes are getting
increasingly interesting actually and
particularly in the city of black holes
we can get onto that but um so yes
wormholes are allowed geometries in
Einstein's theory general relativity if
you just take that theory alone what do
I mean by that so they really are
shortcuts through space and time so you
can imagine you know traveling from New
York to Sydney it takes a long time you
go around the surface of the Earth or
you could tunnel through and you could
get there quicker so so yes if wormholes
exist and you could travel through them
and they were big enough and stay able
enough then you can build a time machine
and now virtually every physicist who
works on this and Kip Thorne actually
we've got Nobel prize for the
gravitational waves did quite a lot of
interesting work on this when you add
quantum mechanics into the mix which is
the theory of everything else because
our universe hasn't just got gravity in
it it's got all sorts of other things in
it as well obviously atoms and
electromagnetic radiation and so on then
it seems like the wormholes are
inherently unstable the big ones and if
you try to travel through one it
collapses so that's basically I should
say by the way that they're part of
they're such an integral part of
Einstein's theory it's a very famous
paper in the 1930s by Einstein and Rosen
and they they were called Einstein Rose
and bridges before they were wormholes
and they're they're built into the basic
description of a black hole if the black
hole had listed lives forever it's
called The Eternal the maximally
extended Swatch chilled metric right
whatever it's called but it was that
which was discovered by so what chilled
in 1916 just after the theory was
published then there's a wormhole in
there right so they're just fundamental
to the theory but most physicists
believe and Stephen Hawking wrote a
paper actually called the chronology
protection conjecture conjecture very
thought about this they will be unstable
yeah I can even say you can say I can't
say it chronology protection conjecture
um but that these things would not be
stable and you can't travel through them
so you can't build time machines however
it's worth saying that wormholes are
becoming very very fashionable now in
What's called the ER equals epr Paradigm
so Einstein Rosen ER is Einstein Rosen
this thing from the 1930s where Einstein
and Rosen noticed that they these
geometries exist in space-time or can
exist epr is Einstein podolsky and Rosen
spooky action at a distance it's quantum
entanglement
and so what now is very fashionable and
looks is one of the best explanations of
how information gets out of a black hole
is that this plays a role so you can
there's a kind of a dual description so
we've got quantum entanglement which is
this spooky action at a distance thing
where you separate things to large
distances and they're still
um linked in some way and the linked in
some way is starting to look possibly
like you can describe that in terms of
wormholes microscopic wormholes linking
them together but this is really this is
stuff that's been done now 2020 2022 so
it's um it's on the edge but people are
taking it okay so wait let's let's pause
there and come back but all right now
you've established that we agree we can
think about wormholes but you haven't
told us how to go backwards in time so
Brian how do you use wormholes to
actually travel backwards in time is
that possible well so yeah if if they
were stable
or you could stabilize them in some way
then you could use them as time machines
um
and uh that's considered to be unlikely
um but it really is true to say that we
do well it's very true to say we don't
have What's called the quantum theory of
gravity so we don't really in any sense
understand the the Deep merger between
relativity and quantum mechanics which
you need to understand to answer that
question and many physicists point out
that we don't you know it feels like
it's no way to build the universe we've
all seen that to the future we all know
the paradoxes that happen if you if time
travel is a reality so so I think if you
pushed most physicists and said don't be
formal about it and don't say what I
just said which is we don't understand
quantum gravity yet
um then most physicists would say okay
we think the laws of nature will be such
that there aren't stable
macroscopic big wormholes and that's
what I think most physicists would say
and but actually you mentioned
Interstellar
um and Kip Thorn is one of the world
experts on this does point out that you
can get around this so you could have a
universe uh which committed time travel
and was not full of contradictions if
there were no Free Will at all
so the whole universe itself is
completely consistent and the time
travel is built into the consistencies I
think Kurt Runner you got it right uh
correct me if I'm wrong Brian he just
described your life is always there
you're always being born you're always
dying you're always in school you're
always in love and you just rejoin where
you were on that timeline and relive
that there's a Stephen Hawking's
birthday part knows keep Thorns birthday
parties there's a preceding so it's a
Neil on a when we go to Scientific
conferences you have a proceedings it's
a big thing and there's a proceedings
but I think it's Kit I think it's his
60th birthday party and Stephen Hawking
gave her a talk and it's written up in
the proceedings of his birthday party
because he's so eminent and and Stephen
said um said that kit has become
increasingly interested in time travel
through wormholes as he's got older
that's good
[Laughter]
[Music]
uh the movie
Monsters Inc was all about wormholes
did you see monsters and you have kids
you saw Monsters Inc I did several times
I've seen that okay the doors yeah I see
what you're saying they're manufacturing
doors it's a monsters take home and then
they open the door that is the door of
the closet of the kid that you have to
scare that night that's right okay and
there's a big chase scene where they're
going in and out of doors in the factory
and they show up in Paris and they show
up in in you know in 20 different places
with every door they pass through those
are wormholes so instead of a
transporter which molecularly I'm
getting there you're exactly right you
Chuck that's my next thing so my point
is if you just walk through a door you
walk through a door right okay that's
the Wormhole then the transporter in
Star Trek which dematerializes you beams
your energy at the speed of light to a
location and then you get
re-materialized right would be
completely unnecessary yeah exactly you
just pop the hatch walk through and now
you're in the other spaceship now you're
on the planetary surface why did you
have to take me apart exactly you
completely took me apart completely yeah
okay plus there's some episode I was
told maybe in the later series because
I'm less complete in the later series
that there is some fraction of your
molecules that are not transported and
constituted
They're copying errors yeah that's well
that's why they have the uh buffer it's
called The Transporter buffer system
because of that it compensates for that
which is why sometimes which is so lazy
but it I love it it works it's like
somebody gets lost and they're just like
Well what we'll do is we'll use the
transporter buffer to take all of their
molecular imprint and then we'll just
make them make bring the person back oh
okay okay so they don't they don't
really die in a pile of goo right right
okay exactly all right what's
interesting there is
we're in the age of information which
was not so in the 1960s right and so
they weren't thinking about information
in the same way or at all and so all you
really need to do is make an exact copy
of all the information that is contained
within you all the neurosynaptic
configurations and everything and then
beam the information to another ship and
then recreate you there and then what
that means is I can create you in any
location and I can create multiple views
that's right and I mean why not they do
that with the with the replicator all
right that's right that's all the
replicator does that's all it does yeah
so in principle if you have a replicator
you don't need a transporter system okay
we just have the information of who you
are and transport that but so that's one
thing you would do with a wormhole okay
so we have monster scaring children
that's first application so just a
second I love it
otherwise how they're going to get in
your in the kids room there's no way
they can get in exactly another thing is
imagine if the back of your refrigerator
were connected to your grocer
oh wow he'd stock it the same way he
stocks the shelves at the grocery at the
grocery store
they take a peek oh you'd be low on
lettuce and the lettuce is turning bad
they'll take out the lettuce put in a
fresh one and there is no Transportation
Network involved say goodbye GrubHub the
the the in yeah so GrubHub is is a is a
practical Wormhole right by the way you
know what else a wormhole is another is
an elevator
think about it you walk into a room the
door closes and then when the door
reopens you're in a completely different
time and place that's actually kind of
you know you know yes that think about
that if you before electricity and
before elevators and before tall
buildings just grabbed someone off the
street and take them into a modern
elevator okay oh my God and then the
doors you know they're on a street level
or something and then they push a button
and then they open it up and then
they're 100 stories up and they'll freak
out how did that happen the room didn't
change I didn't see anything there were
no windows what happened so for me an
elevator is a modern sort of next best
thing to a wormhole that you can come up
with yeah right you could be in one room
and then take an elevator and then
there's a kitchen and another room and
then it's like a living room or whatever
you know and and so just the world
changes just in a matter of seconds so
uh so what do we have so we have the
elevator is a poor man's Wormhole yeah
we've got scaring children and their
closet we've got the transporter in Star
Trek go to the back of your refrigerator
and what that ends up doing is
completely removing
Transportation sector from the world
for the rest of my life
I don't have to do anything
since every Galaxy we observed so far
has had a supermassive black hole at the
center of it and theoretically a black
hole could be turned into a worm hole
what if they were used as save points
like in a video game across space and
time for a creator of sorts to get
across galaxies more quickly to create
what we know as space I think what he
wants is
because black holes and wormholes are
related and may be related okay and he
wants to know whether there's some I I
might be exaggerating his question okay
whether there's some Intergalactic
highway system yes that connects one
galaxy to another yeah Across the
Universe right through these black holes
what are these black holes in other
words like it's you know kind of like uh
what's that what's that City a
Minneapolis that's what I'm trying to
think of yeah they have they have you
walk you walk it you never have to go
outside I mean when it's 40 below really
cold walk between buildings right so
buildings are connected so you never
have to go out yeah exactly so here's
the thing nobody would live the idea
more than I would if a black hole which
only eats things is a portal to a
wormhole
the other side of that wormhole
can't also be a black hole right it has
because then you would be shoving things
out that was that's called a white hole
oh really yes now see what white hole
got to be give
me gift hold gotta be taken so is there
really a white hole that's why my
parents know that that's a double
reference back there's the the group
from the Civil Right Now not the movie
that's right right and the guy that uses
vibranium so yeah yeah
so where were we we're talking about the
fact that there is something called a
white hole yes so something called a
whitehead that you didn't just I did not
totally make it up and this was explored
in the 1970s okay when the mathematics
of black holes were coming to maturity
and someone posited well if you have a
black hole it what's on the other side
it would be like a white hole I mean I
mean why not where everything only comes
out right then how would you connect
them with a wormhole so this you got
this you get three for one right deal on
that and then you can ask yourself what
a white hole would look like in the
universe so in 1970s we said if this is
what a white hole would look like let's
check the data let's let's go to the
universe right nothing in the universe
resembled it not even quasars which are
intense emanations of light from the
distant Universe in a very small volume
so
we uh so we abandoned that okay so if
you could I don't mind wormholes
connecting the galaxies I just don't see
how you would invoke the black hole to
do that to do it that's it all right
great question we're gonna take a break
yep before we get lost in the Black Hole
bag
[Music]